on this fine July day in a small town on
this street at number 32 Jack lives with
his family quite by chance Jessica lives
at number 34
well these two children have the same
career opportunities Jack and Jessica
are growing up together they have become
inseparable and to the best of playmates
I'm going to build dams like dad says
Jack and I'm going to work at the
hospital like mum replies Jessica years
have gone by jack is following in his
father's footsteps he will become an
engineer after originally considering a
career as a nurse
Jessica settles on law in Europe 60% of
recent graduates are women but
traditions and stereotypes influence
education and career choices by women
and men
in the health and education sectors
women make up 75% of all workers these
female dominated economic sectors are
less valued Jack and Jessica now work
for the same company Jack manages large
construction sites for the company
Jessica is a manager in the human
resources department both love their
work but Jessica's work is less
prestigious her job is considered a
woman's profession less strategic and
less visible on average a woman earns
around 17% less than a man in Europe
everyone agrees that Jessica is very
talented but this talent is not always
recognized for the same skills invisible
barriers created by prejudices prevent
women from rising to positions of
responsibility Jack the manager travels
a lot and often works late jessica is
still waiting to be promoted but after
all wasn't she the one who decided to
cut back on her working hours 78% or
more than 3/4 of part-time workers are
women many years later
Jessica and Jack have reached retirement
age
Jessica never had the chance of working
full-time again her pension has been
affected as a result but Jessica knows
that things can change
the european union is taking action
against the gender pay gap
it has adopted legislation to tackle pay
discrimination the European Commission
is launching an information campaign to
raise awareness about the causes of the
gender pay gap and to promote equality
at work